like that before i never had anybody
here for dinner let alone made love on
the table
but somehow i just want to do that i
just want to like dance i just want to
like you know
put on some shirelles i just i want to
be black
that's pete davidson documenting his
weekend with scott disick but now i'll
be honest even on a night off from snl
the comedian still uses his saturdays to
make people laugh
and this time his audience is the lord's
instagram followers i don't know what's
going on anymore after taking over the
reality star's insta account pete
reveals he's the last one awake showing
scott and some pals asleep in front of a
tv
sorry i never had any video for
dinner they love
the table
but somehow i just want to do that i
just want to like dance i just want to
like you know
put on some charelles i want to be black
adding the cheeky caption quote boys
night was wild and let's just watch this
moment one more time
i never had any video for dinner let
alone made love on the table
but somehow i just want to do that i
just want to like dance i just want to
like you know
put on some shirelles i just i want to
be black
this comes as it is learning new details
about pete and girlfriend kim kardashian
in her public battles with estranged
husband kaye west there's no such thing
as 50 50 custody
with with in society today that's not
that's not even
it always leans towards the mob
a source tells e.t quote despite the
struggle she's having with kanye kim is
really enjoying herself with pete she
feels like she is having fun with him
like she never has before she feels so
relaxed around him and like her true
self
the source adds quote things are getting
more and more serious between them i
always saw such a good example in my mom
and my dad in their relationship so i'm
always just hopeful kim is also opening
up about co-parenting with the rapper
recently telling ellen degeneres she's
sticking to the high road no matter what
goes on you know it's the father of my
kids i'll always be protective i always
want my kids to just see the best of the
best
so i just try to as hard as it can be
sometimes i do try to ignore it and just
try to do whatever's best for the kids
that's what i love about you because
take the high road yeah
this interview comes after kanye's
constant social media rants from
questioning kim's parenting abilities
i said i'm not allowing my daughter
to be used by tick-tock to sharing a
music video featuring a claymation
figure that seemingly resembles pete
god sent me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis's ass
meanwhile jonathan chubbin one of kim's
besties recently voiced the et his
support for her new relationship as
kim's one of kim's closest confidants
what do you think of her and pete
together um i think it's cool you know
what she's having fun i guess you know
uh you know i i've hung out with them a
couple of times and
you know i love her to death so whatever
whatever makes her happy ask her friend
how are you supporting her through all
the kind of the kanye craziness that's
happening i don't even know anything
about that so i love kanye too man he's
a genius excuse me um but you know
listen i just i hope that i hope
everybody
ends up settling